se cumplen 100 días de Gustavo Petro en
el poder el primer presidente de
izquierda de Colombia ha tenido una
agenda ocupada en la Esfera
internacional un mes después de
posicionarse entregó un discurso sin
rodeos y en tono desafiante ante la
asamblea general de la ONU acusó a las
grandes potencias del deterioro del
medio ambiente y calificó la lucha
contra las drogas como un fracaso por
ocultar la verdad ver al morir la selva
y las democracias la guerra contra las
drogas ha fracasado la lucha contra la
crisis climática ha fracasado
han aumentado los consumos mortales de
drogas suaves han pasado a las más duras
Se ha producido un genocidio en mi
continente y en mi país han condenado a
las cárceles a millones de personas
a finales de agosto Petro avanzó de
forma rápida hacia el restablecimiento
de las relaciones con Venezuela país con
el que comparte más de 2.300 kilómetros
de Frontera
apertura de los pasos fronterizos puso
fin a siete años de cierre creo que hoy
es un día histórico
para la región para el país para América
del Sur
Gustavo Petro se reunió con el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken para tratar su idea de
bandera de paz total y recientemente
estuvo con el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron para hablar sobre
Venezuela paz y transición energética a
nivel económico en estos 100 días la
moneda colombiana se ha devaluado
considerablemente respecto al dólar
estadounidense el 7 de agosto día de la
posesión la cotización del peso era de
unos 4.300 por dólar en noviembre superó
de forma histórica el pico de los 5000
pesos y actualmente ronda los 4.800
según el banco de la república